In this video,
we're unboxing and building
our most recent kit,
the Spy Scope,
used to view things up close,
and uncover secret messages.
[Music]
Guys, the new King
of Random kit is here.
That's right.
In the past,
we have shown you
how to making microscope
using your cell phone,
and some other little parts.
Well, we're happy to announce
that our new kit is everything
you need to build one of those,
minus the phone itself.
You have to
provide that yourself.
All right, so I wasn't here for
the original microscope build,
so I want to take this part.
I want to see what's inside,
and I want to put it together.
And we've actually
gone ahead and made
a few improvements as well.
So this should be
a little bit easier to assemble
than the original
plans I showed.
Open it up.
Let's see what we've got.
A block of wood.
Everything I ever wanted.
The finest quality.
All right, 2 sheets of acrylic.
Now, explain to me
why there are two.
It comes with two
just as a backup.
When I made the original video,
I talked about how
when you're drilling acrylic,
you have to be really careful
not to break and crack the pane,
and that is still a worry.
So I believe there's
just an extra one
in case something breaks.
You can try again,
and be even more careful.
Nice.
We'll also use the second piece
to score and snap off a section
of acrylic to use
as a slide holder.
Here are some things,
I don't know what they are.
Flast Light.
Okay, that makes more sense.
Batteries included.
In the original one,
we had a different
taller flashlight,
and we had to drill a hole
into the wood to hold it up
straight and stuff like that,
and I use that
because it was available
at Home Depot for really cheap.
But we've got
these flashlights instead.
They're very bright.
They're easy to position.
They actually have a little
sticky pad at the bottom,
so you can place it,
and then just stick
it down to the wood,
and it's going to hold in place
right where you want it forever.
Awesome.
All of our Hardware.
We've got some bolts, some nuts,
some springs, some washers.
And then, the lens itself.
We have a tiny little lens.
Very tiny.
Which we do not have to take out
of a cat exercising
laser pointer this time.
It does come with a diagram of
how all the pieces go together.
So we've got our three bolts.
Those are what's
holding everything up.
We've got nuts
and washers throughout.
We've got some springs.
That's going to hold
our slide holder just
where we want it.
That will help us
with focusing a little bit.
We need to drill some holes
into both the plastic sheets
and the wooden base,
and then we
place our flashlight.
And it does have on here,
additional tools
required for assembly:
a cellphone with a camera.
We've got that.
Drill.
Drill bit, a 1-1/4
inch drill bit.
And optionally, spray paint,
and that's if you want to change
the color of the whole base.
You don't need to do that,
but it can look
a little slicker if you do.
We want to drill
through both acrylic sheets
and the wooden base
at the same time.
That way, all of the holes are
going to be perfectly lined up.
And since we're drilling
all the way through this,
we don't want to drill
into the workbench,
like I may have done
at some point in the past.
So we've got just
some scrap wood underneath it.
Masking tape is of course
the strongest type
of tape in the world.
>> Oh, wait, no, sorry.
>> This is undisputed.
Sorry.
One of the weakest.
That's what I meant.
But it should do
a pretty good job
of holding everything in place.
All we needed to do is
keep everything aligned
as we drill holes into it.
Okay, we've got
the quarter inch drill bit,
and we need to drill one,
two, three holes
through all the acrylic
and the wooden base.
And the one thing we
really need to make sure is
that we have enough space
in between these two
to fit our cell phone.
We want the camera
to be somewhere
above this smaller rectangle.
Okay.
And we want to make sure we have
enough space on the sides
that the phone fits nicely
in between the to.
When drilling acrylic,
you want to put
very little pressure,
and just very carefully
drill down through it.
If you've got too much pressure,
it's really likely to drill
through a lot of it,
and then at the back,
when the acrylic sheet
gets really thin--
It's gonna snap.
It pushes through and snaps.
So that's the second reason
that we've got things
stacked up like this.
It does help with alignment,
but it also really helps
with not pushing out the back.
When the piece of acrylic
is pushed up against something else,
the drill bit isn't going
to shove right through
and break it.
Hopefully, this will
stop anything from
cracking and breaking.
But just in case,
we do have another sheet.
Let's see how this goes.
Oh, we're into the wood.
And it just keep going
all the way down through.
Got it.
Is this good?
I didn't hear any cracking
or anything like that.
So I think that worked great.
That's all the way through.
Got it.
[Music]
I think we're good.
I think we can take
the tape off,
and hopefully, all of our
acrylic sheets are uncracked.
All right, I think
this one's okay.
Nice.
Slight scratched,
but I don't think
it's gonna affect us any.
There is one more hole that we
need to drill in this one,
and that's where we're going
to put the lens.
Now, we're going
to take the phone,
and we're going to start
a set it right in between,
trying to line the camera
up right in between
those two drilled holes.
And now, we're going
to lift this up.
Here, I'll lift it.
You can marker and mark--
All right.
There.
We've got a mark.
Now, we need to drill
a hole for that as well.
And it needs to be
the same size as the lens.
The lens should fit
into a 1-1/4 inch hole.
But if you drill it too big,
then it's going to fall through,
and you're gonna have a really
hard time getting into stay.
I think we'll still use
the 1-1/4 inch hole,
and then if it's not fitting,
we'll put the drill in
and we'll just slightly
ease it around to widen
the hole just enough
that the lens will start to fit.
If you look at the side
of the lens,
there's going to be one side
of it that's pretty much flat.
There's the plastic
housing goes around,
and there's the top of the lens.
This lens is flat on one side,
and domed on the other,
and we want it pointing down.
So the dome side is looking
at what we're focusing on.
With the correct side identified,
we're now going to press the lens
down into the hole that we drilled.
And I've got a piece
of paper towel under it now,
just so I don't accidentally
press the lens onto something
that's going to scratch it up.
[Music]
Perfect.
We now got a lens embedded
into the acrylic sheet.
Everything's ready
to be assembled.
But we should at least
customize it a little bit.
Let's paint it
before we assemble.
The instructions do say
spray paint optional.
We accept the option.
[Music]
Fancy?
What was that sound again?
So for the next part
of the assembly,
this is pretty simple.
You're going to take
all of your bolts.
You're going to put them up
through your base,
and just sort of layer
all of your pieces
as you see them.
Make sure that your acrylic has
the plastic remove
before you do this.
There's our rubber gaskets.
We need our washers first.
The nuts.
Wing nuts, upside down.
And Nate, you're saying
that we're going to be adjusting
these according to the height
of where we need
them for the light.
[Music]
It disconnects if you need
to replace the batteries,
but the base stays right
where you put it.
[Music]
The phone--
Will be sitting on top.
Right like this.
So you can see whatever's
on this slide.
Yes.
So we're going to be
adjusting that slide
up and down depending on
where we want our focus.
All right, I think we're good.
What should we put on it?
Well, there's lots of things
that we looked at before.
We looked at a penny.
We looked at some leaf pieces.
But we actually
have something else.
This is the kit as it comes,
minus the sticker,
which we still need
to attach down at the bottom.
However, we also
we're going to be having
some slides you can get.
So we have here the slide pack
that it comes with.
Oh, that's fun.
With some cool little bits
of nature in it.
This is some Lotus root,
dandelion fuzz,
sponge gourd stem,
and pine tree stem.
So in addition to these
four slides of nature,
we have these
additional challenge slides,
and these are
actually pretty fun.
Hidden within these slides
are some letters,
and if you find the letters,
you can enter them
as a promotional code
into our website.
TheKingofRandom.com/ the
unscrambled letters.
It makes a phrase.
If you unscramble those letters,
plug them in and go
to the hidden web site.
You can receive a bonus code
for an extra challenge.
Holy cow.
That is so cool.
There it is.
Look at that.
That-- Okay.
That's really just creepy.
But awesome.
Wow, Lotus root is full
of a lot of really tiny holes.
[Music]
Looks like little alien.
For some types of slides, or
things that you're going to look at,
if it has a lot of holes in it,
then this LED can be
a little bit intense.
It's pretty bright
and sharp lighting.
So if you want to diffuse
that a little bit,
it's really easy to take just
a piece of white paper towel
or white printer paper,
and just set it right
over the light.
A lot of light
still gets through.
It's just a little bit softer.
We're just cutting
the pieces of plastic
that all of our little tools
and supplies came in.
Just make some really
quick makeshift slides,
because I want to try some
of our pen ink slime.
This would looked really
pretty through the lights.
[Music]
Wait.
This is gonna be cool.
[Music]
That's so cool.
There are a lot of really
small bubbles in there.
Not just bubbles though.
I think we're actually seeing
like tiny bits of pigmentation.
It looks like little Galaxy.
This phone is turning green.
I know.
That's weird.
Because we've seen purple,
we've seen green.
It really just depended on
how thick we made that slime.
But that's weird.
Guys, that's the kit.
The whole thing goes together
pretty quick and easy.
It works great,
and it should work
with pretty much any cellphone
that has a camera on the back.
This thing is really--
It's so fun.
The thing is fun.
It's crazy what things
look like up close.
So the kits' available now.
Click the link
in the description,
and go to TheKingofRandom.com
to get yours.
And of course, there are also
these little bonus slides.
These come with some cool
cross-sections of stuff
that are great to look at,
along with these images.
These are the ones that
have hidden letters in them.
Go through, find all
the hidden letters,
assemble them into a phrase,
that will take you to a website
where you can get even
more bonus content.
Should be great fun.
Guys, that's not all.
We've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top will take
you to our latest video,
and that box at the bottom is
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
Hit this bomb in the middle
to subscribe to the club.
So you never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.